[Applaudissements]
voilà tous
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
public laspalès oui oui oui j'avais
demandé le look de thierry de l'amour
est dans le pré
on m'a le filet le look de de funès dans
la soupe aux choux et en plus on veut
l'appeler la brader bieber qui veut y
aller qui va de soi et oublie même alors
enfin le plan conjoint de carine
meillard n'est pas du sud un énorme en
est mais moi je vis dans le manger ça se
voit pas mais l'accent n'est pas
exactement le choc à venir
bousquet lui rien c'est mal et c'est un
sketch pour l'asie désert ce matin la
radio et à passer par un personnage
qu'est un personnage pourrait on dire
qu'on est dans l'approximation
je suis des galaxies je viens vous
prises excusez-moi j'ai fait chaud je
suis garé moi j'ai pas blanc et rouge
j'ai poussé dominé n'existe pas je te
connais pas alors on va vous interpellez
petite chanson sur l'équipe tout cela
qu'ils peuvent deviner sur lesquels vous
allez devoir deviner des gonzesses la
télévision les gonzes est donc chez vous
aussi vous allez devoir trouver des
animatrices de télévision c'est sur
exactement les fidji dont 14 sociaux
aussi jouer il va donc choper des
animatrices de télévision pour vous car
il est cet indice et j'y mettrais bien
un coup de tuyaux
[Applaudissements]
mais trouver la musique présente
résoudre à la télévision à 20h juste
avant que jean les moutons si je sais
que j'ai une balle dans le canon
je suis fidèle au poste même si je suis
fait comme un jambon est plaisante le
journal à la télévision là où on pouvait
les consommations mais très bien coûte
police d'ottawa non
je regarde que tf1 après je mets la
viande dans le champ à ce que vous avez
trouvé
claire chazal sait exactement à 10 alors
parce que plus que je mettrais bien
coutumier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était comme dans les dix ans à l'âge
où les pas présentés non sifflé jacky le
biko le roi de l'accordéon
vous avez une très belle voix un indice
alors j'y mettrais bien couture et on va
vite aller musique
on la voit présenter toutes sortes de
bêtises et moi je la toule comida même
quand je suis plein comme un cartable
suit pas et maquillée comme une voiture
volée je la trouverai contraire je la
prendrais bien dans les poubelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit bras son village
mais la moto culte et je crois que je
vais faire un carton
j'en parle avec mes potes du sel et
polyglotte et moi je lui tape revient
dans la botte
[Musique]
sud ouest et l'est sur les doigts
taurian actu
victoria silvsted victorien sucette
mais c'est ça pourquoi pourquoi lundi ce
match que je mettrais bien coups de
tuyaux
cette fois-ci vous avez tomber se lavera
à leurs impressions le trois derniers
tout le monde connaît un indice qui
mettrait bien couture musique
[Musique]
j'ai fait la star les anges de la télé
réalité
inventel post it c'est vrai
simard trop quoi pouvait avoir des
mamelles aussi ronde on résoudrait la
faim dans le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'est ce qu'a dit elle à la corde
dans la folie une paire de boeufs
c'est de la folie merci merci
la synergie solo
[Musique]
là bas
c'est le même sens et toutes les
chansons dans ma bouche bée d'accord
même chose
est ce que vous avez trouvé car oui oui
mais je serai plus son prénom labrune
alloua loire oui alors oui la belle à
nabila abid
[Applaudissements]